hi everybody i'm margaret smith i'm the
corn breeder here in plant breeding and
genetics at cornell university
we have a very applied field corn
breeding program and a tiny bit of sweet
corn breeding that we do so i'd just
like to tell you about our program in
general and then a few specific
illustrations since our time is short of
some of the things we're working on
right now
new york state is a state where dairy is
the primary agricultural enterprise and
one of the primary feedstuffs for that
dairy is corn both grain and silage
so field corn is one of the most
important crops in the state it occupies
about a million acres of land here in
new york
and we try to breed field corn in my
program for what i would call niches so
new york state is a bit of a niche
compared to where most of the corn
production in the u.s is because we have
a shorter growing season we tend to have
weather like this not in july but this
year it's in july wearing a coat in the
field in july is a really unusual event
but in our in the fall particularly our
weather tends to be very cool and wet so
we have some unique challenges during
the harvest season that you don't see in
the main parts of the central corn belt
and in the spring our ground tends to be
very wet so we folk we need varieties
which will work with cool wet soil
conditions in the spring and lots of
cloudy wet weather in the fall so that's
some of what makes new york state corn a
niche
another niche we work on is organics we
have a lot of organic growers and the
organic average is increasing so we do a
bit of reading work for organics
and then the other thing that i do to
complement both of those is a lot of
work on developing sources of resistance
to diseases and insects
so that's the kind of overview of some
of our major breeding objectives
we have a breeding nursery site here in
aurora new york which is about 35 miles
north of ithaca it's a major corn
growing part of the state if i were to
grow my breeding nursery near campus
not only is it a little even shorter
season than what we have to deal with
here so there are a lot of things i
couldn't effectively cross or work with
because the growing season is too short
there
but also it's not a major corn growing
area so i get every deer raccoon student
needing a decoration for their porch and
everything else taking a big toll on my
field so we grew our corn up here in
keuka county which is one of the larger
dairy and field crops producing counties
in new york state surrounded by lots of
acres of fields porn to dilute out all
of those
deer and raccoon and bird problems and
so on that we otherwise would have to
deal with
so our breeding nursery is here at
aurora
in addition to the breeding program we
have a variety testing program
that involves sites
seven conventional on-farm sites two
organic sites
and those are all focused on grain
testing corn testing for grain
we also do both commercial commercial
corn testing for grain as well as for
silage so we have four additional silage
testing sites that we run here in new
york state together with a team of folks
from animal science and in collaboration
with colleagues in vermont so we have a
vermont new york corn silage testing
program which is nice because it picks
up on a lot of the similarities of those
growing environments and the fact that
vermont also is a very big dairy state
so it gives us a broader sampling of
sites a nice collaboration that we can
do for the commercial variety testing
between those two locations
so that's the quick overview of the
scope of our program
um i want to start by talking about a
little of the work we've been doing on
organic corn breeding
and it's always unclear what makes a
variety perform better in organic
conditions than another
it seems fairly apparent that not
necessarily
the best varieties in conventional
growing systems will always be the best
for organic growing systems and you can
imagine a lot of the conditions that
would make that true the organic growers
tend to plant later because they're
having a
legume or some other kind of cover crop
plow down before they can get in the
fields
they plant without commercial synthetic
seed treatment chemicals so germination
and establishment is really important
they
do a lot of aggressive weak control so
you have to have a variety that will
withstand that but translating that kind
of thing those those
um speculations as to traits that
nitrogen would be another one nitrogen
availability is a more gradual process
compared to synthetic nitrogen which you
know you pour on
some is a starter and a bunch is a side
dress it comes in big flushes for the
organic corn nitrogen is a more gradual
slow to start in the spring
stretched out over the season
availability
so you can imagine a lot of things that
would cause a variety to be better
adapted to that than to conventional and
vice versa but most of those are
speculative and they're hard to
translate into specific traits that i'm
going to look for as i go through my
nursery and say i'm selecting for this
because that will make the better
organic corn
so we do a lot of our selection for
organics based on variety evaluation
organic systems looking at what works
well trying to make new combinations
among some of the best performing things
and re-selecting those sort of standard
approach to trying to improve adaptation
and yield performance in a corn breeding
program
figure out what works try and combine
things that work well to get something
even better
one of the things we've done is a little
unique in our organic
breeding effort is
i worked with colleagues kevin
montgomery out in illinois and a
colleague of his to do cold stress
testing on seeds and seedlings so i
mentioned that we have cold wet soils in
the spring that organic those fields
need to be able to establish and get
going without the benefit of a seed
treatment and that they need to
establish and get going quickly because
you need canopy cover to help with that
weed control problem managing weeds is
one of the biggest challenges in an
organic system
so we took segregating populations so
these would be f2 populations
subjected them to a cold stress test so
put the seeds in water to hydrate them
then put them in cold temperature
conditions for several days then move
them to germination um
petri dishes or or paper towels for
germination
took the ones which germinated well and
planted them to the field and that whole
part was done by my colleague out in
illinois and his collaborator planted
them out in the field and self the
things which happen to grow well despite
having been mistreated in that way as
seeds and seedlings
and then we're doing breeding with those
so one of the things that the progenies
i'm standing in front of happen to be
things that have emerged as a result of
that
we screened them as s2s they were self
as s3s we test crossed them as an early
generation test and put them in an
organic
yield trial
and took the best of them these are now
s4s were advancing and test crossing
again
to see whether that gives us a fraction
of that original population that has
better
better establishment better tolerance
cold wet soils more rapid early vigor
and canopy closure to help with weed
control so i'll be trying to answer the
question of whether that subset of the
f2
is a better performing subset in organic
conditions than if we had just used our
standard approach to early generation
breeding and selection
our entire nursery here is done without
seed treatment but the challenges in a
conventional nursery like this are less
than what you were going to find in an
organic nursery or an organic grower's
field so we did start these off in the
early generations in our organic
breeding nursery to keep that selection
pressure on and we just like to compare
whether they're going to really help us
because the cold stress test effort as
you might imagine distressing seeds by
pedigree and putting them in germination
plates and hand transplanting them to
the field is a fairly labor intensive
process so we'll see whether that's
likely to work or not
another area i'd like to talk about is
our disease and insect resistance
breeding so we do this program
historically has done a lot of breeding
for resistance to various corn tests
and it fits well into our adaptation
both for conventional and organic so it
feeds into those programs and all the
progenies that come out of it go right
into our testing program
so i want to take a few moments to talk
about several of the different pest
resistance efforts that we have ongoing
one of the diseases we've worked a lot
with is the anthracnose stock rot and
the progenies here on my left are some
of the results of some of that selection
so anthracnose stockrot is a
atypical stock rotting organism most of
the stock rots in corn attack the stock
when it's senescing so the plant is
already on the way out the the tissue is
dying the rot moves into that dying
tissue so we call them stock rots of
senescence anthracnose is not like that
it actually attacks stocks when they're
still healthy and vibrant so at around
flowering time or a little before
and what that means is that stocks are
also critically important still in terms
of translocation of water and
photosynthates during that time period
so the fact that the rod is attacking
and moving through the stalk in that
early time in the plant's development
means that it has much more potential to
cause
yield losses you know it's cutting off
photosynthetic transportation to the ear
it's restricting movement of water and
nutrients up from the soil so it can be
really problematic in addition to
weakening the stock and you may remember
at the beginning i said we have all that
cloudy wet weather in the fall which
means our plants have to stay standing
in the field oftentimes longer than
farmers would wish sometimes
they're just not maturing very fast
because of the cool cloudy wet weather
sometimes they're mature enough but the
farmer can't get near them to harvest
because the ground is too wet so stock
quality and standability despite that
are really important to our growers out
here in the northeast
so we've worked on selecting for
resistance to anthrax stockrot i have a
notable memory from speaking about this
to a seed industry meeting and having
one of the industry guys raise his hand
and say margaret you know that all looks
really exciting great resistance levels
but make sure you're not selecting for
resistance to yield too because this is
what often happens we can develop really
resistant things but they're really
resistant maybe because they aren't even
growing an ear there's nothing drawing
the nutrients out of the stock to begin
with or just because they seem to take a
big yield hit so our techno stockrot
breeding program we have run by doing
every generation along the way we'll
take our selected progenies that appear
to have stock rot resistance cross them
to a stock susceptible tester to
evaluate that resistance in a hybrid
combination to make sure they're
transferring resistance to their hybrid
progeny and simultaneously cross that
line to a good yield tester so that we
can look at those hybrids and make sure
we're not breeding for resistance to
yield
so the proteins on my left here are some
of the ones that have come out of an
effort that started in the germplasm
enhancement of maize program which was a
federally funded effort
to
enhance the diversity in commercial maze
germplasm it was a collaborative effort
between the maze the corn seed industry
and the public sector breeders and a
variety of hubs where the the gem or
germplasm enhancement of may's program
was centered so we got some funding
early on to work with that we identified
progenies the one that i'm standing next
to happens to have come from a variety
that came from chile but
varieties that had come from the
germplasm collections largely from the
tropics and subtropics that are hugely
diverse in maize but have not been
widely used in commercial breeding
so these are some of the things emerging
from that breeding effort for
anthracnose stock rot the resistance is
looking really good we will inject these
right into the base of the stock with
stock rot and split the stocks at
harvest to evaluate how far the stock
rifles traveled up the stocks make sure
we're selecting for resistance and then
in the background behind me the stuff
that's really tall you can see are some
of the test cross hybrids that are being
evaluated for anthracnose stock rot
resistance so as i mentioned each
generation of the way s2s s3s s4s we are
crossing simultaneously to both a rod
susceptible tester to evaluate the
contribution of this progeny to the
stock rod of the hybrid and that's the
hybrid evaluation going on behind me and
at the same time
a yield potential tester to evaluate its
contribution and adequacy and adaptation
for yield and productivity here in new
york
so that's some of our anthracnose
stockrot work
one of the other things that acts
synergistically with the anthracnose rot
is the european corn borer
there is less of a problem with that now
because of the widespread use of bt corn
but there are still a number of
circumstances where growers may not want
to use or be able to use the bt as a
control mechanism for european corn
borer so you can imagine organic growers
are not using those things
and growers who are planting bt also
need refuge acres that are non-bt
thirdly i maintain that having some
innate corn based resistance in the
background of bt will probably help to
ensure the longevity and the
effectiveness over time the durability
of that bt-based resistance so for all
those reasons we've continued to work on
european corn borer resistance and the
european corn borer has been shown to
act synergistically with the anthracnose
stock rot so if you have corn borers
creating holes in the stock you have
entry points for the rot
there is some evidence that the corn
borers can even vector in the
anthracnose anthracnose will cause a
leaf light disease phase which can
produce spores that can then be carried
in by the insects
incidentally resistance to the leaf
flight phase of the anthracnose disease
is genetically unrelated to resistance
to the stuffrt phase so that makes
selection particularly challenging
but the corn borer can act
synergistically so we've had a
long-standing relationship
with several international programs that
select for borah resistance most notably
the one at the international maze and
wheat improvement center symmet in
mexico
summit developed a multiple border
resistant population
that was selected all across the world
including here in new york for
resistance to an a large array of
different types of borers most of the
tropical and sub-tropical borers are
much more aggressive than the european
corn borer that we primarily deal with
here so having things coming out of that
program provided really strong levels of
resistance to stock boring by the
european corn border this is another
another pest where the leaf damage phase
and resistance to it is genetically
unrelated to resistance to the stock
boring phase so these are the two
classic problems you can select for leaf
feeding resistance but it does nothing
necessarily for stock boring resistance
and as you might imagine
stock boring damage by this insect has
the potential to cause much more yield
loss you've got tunnels through the
stock all the same reasons i talked
about for the anthracnose stock rod
tunnels that cut off translocation
through the stock stock has weakened and
fall over for all of the same reasons
so we took some of these materials from
the multiple bore resistant population
in mexico and also the one that my
former colleague who i miss very much
john mim the entomologist at simmet for
many years
deemed the
brg
um if you worked with john at the time
you would know that brg stands for
bordeaux resistant gringo
so he he called it that because he had
left it from u.s germplasm that's the
gringo part
adjacent to the multiple bore resistant
population and he harvested a bunch of
top crosses off of that so it was
multiple bore resistant by us corn belt
germplasm so that's the brg so this line
right to my right is one of our
progenies that is emerging from that
breeding effort with the brg
we are again selecting for insect
resistance every step of the way as we
inbreed these making test crosses both
to susceptible testers to evaluate
whether the inbred conveys that
resistance to its hybrid progeny and to
commercial testers to evaluate its yield
potential and adaptation and general
productivity
interestingly enough we were struggling
and struggling with crosses to this this
materials
derived from the brg we kept having poor
seat set and i was stewing for a couple
years about what was going wrong with
that and finally the light went off and
i think they have a gametophyte factor a
lot of tropical genetic materials in
corn have floating around in them
gametophyte factors which limit what can
be crossed to it what will pollinate it
successfully and i'm suspecting these
have a gametophyte factor floating
around in them so we're making some
controlled test crosses here in the
nursery this year to evaluate
whether that's actually the case i'm
thinking that's probably a ga1s this is
the same factor that's used in
the white corn industry and the popcorn
industry to prevent
lots of cross-pollination commercial
crops in those in those arenas with u.s
standard us number two yellow dent if
you're trying to grow white corn you
don't want lots of yellow kernels in
there if you're trying to grow popcorn
you have this gametophyte factor to
reduce the chances of
pollination from adjacent field corn
that would decrease the popping quality
of your crop
so we're evaluating those for whether
they do in fact carry this gametophyte
factor and we also have hybrid
evaluations both for yield as well as
for corn bore resistance going on with
some of these new sources from the
famous brg
so the last thing i want to talk about
today i just finished talking about
multiple insect resistance
and i'd like to talk for a moment about
multiple disease resistance
one of the things that's emerged from
our breeding program is a few inbreds to
a pair of inbred sister lines that we
had originally selected for resistance
to gray leaf spot which is one of the
more problematic leaf lights in corn
and upon further evaluation it turned
out that they in fact had a fairly broad
spectrum of disease resistance to not
only gray leaf spot but also northern
leaf blight some level of resistance to
southern leaf blight anthracnose leaf
blight rust and even stewart's wilt
which is a bacterial disease they had
some moderate resistance so we got
interested in the cause of that multiple
disease resistance one of my graduate
students did a fairly big
recombinant
back cross population to try and
understand the genetics underlying that
multiple disease resistance it involved
a lot of different disease evaluations
and paper should be coming out it was
just accepted so paper should be coming
out shortly on that
to cut to the chase he found a number of
different loci several of which are in
areas that have been identified as kind
of hot spots in the maze genome for
disease resistance one of the things
that emerged was the area that contains
the ligulus one gene which has also just
been published as having some
relationship to disease resistance
ligulus one has to do with the formation
of the
the ligul and the oracle and that
leaf blade sheath interface the whole
development pathway there but it also
appears to be linked through perhaps
liguillus ii to some regulatory systems
that may control the salicylic acid
pathway so that would be a logical
reason for it to be perhaps related to
disease resistance so we're still trying
to understand this rather serendipitous
multiple disease resistance we found
but one of the things i'm doing with it
is trying to back cross it into sweet
corn so you may have noticed that this
corn looks a little different from what
we were looking at this is sweet corn so
we are trying to do some generally slow
gradual back crossing to see if we can
move some of that multiple disease
resistance trait into sweet corn a lot
of sweet corns one of the primary things
that they need is a good disease
resistance package
that's the primary thing after the real
primary thing which is good flavor and
quality um so we're focused on how can
we piggyback some sweet corn improvement
in a small way on our large field corn
breeding program that's by far the
biggest part of my effort and so this is
one of the examples so the progenies i'm
standing in front of right now are a
bunch of progenies that have been
we're doing back crossing with selfie
generations in between and then we
screen those selfie generations for
several different diseases you can
imagine this takes a lot of field space
and a bit of time to get through several
diseases and especially when you know
you have the year where the anthracnose
doesn't do anything in the year where we
don't happen to have any rust or the
year where we have way too much of one
disease and you can't even see the rest
of them but we are slowly trying to move
some of these genes into a sweet corn
background
probably from our program that won't be
a commercial sweet corn that will be a
source material that the industry or
other sweet corn breeders could use in
their breeding efforts
so there's a quick lightning tour of
some of the major breeding objectives
we're working on in my program i hope
you've enjoyed it and i hope you have a
great time attending all of the other
talks that are part of this meeting
thanks very much
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu